i am curious if do you think that if the
eternals were able to fight if they'd
been the ones fighting thanos
um back you know uh instead of everyone
else would they have won or would thanos
have beaten them
you can't predict the future
you never know you can you would never
know
but you understand why they wouldn't
sure i can yes i can have i can debate
it both ways but i won't press you on
this uh i am curious though i want to uh
how did you manage to be the one
to put in the first mcu love scene and
the first representation of an lgbtq
relationship i just want to say congrats
thank you i i gave that credit to marvel
because when i came into the pro process
that was already written in the
treatment
whether that's gonna you know my job is
to make sure they're not just there
existing on screen
for the sake of existing
i my job is to make sure these fields
are very human and authentic moments
but the foundation was laid out by
marvel and by nate and kevin the fur
pulse when they wrote the story
i'm glad that uh i'm especially glad the
second thing got included um i love
talking about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so i am curious for you um how
long was the cut that you had of this
movie where you're like
i don't know how we're gonna get it
shorter
yeah
the thing is i i can handle long movies
uh oh hi yeah yeah like i i mean the
fantasy i picked was the genre sci-fi
fantasy i picked that we were playing in
so
uh those films usually are longer
um
i think it was a few scenes longer than
that yeah and i had to let some babies
go but yeah you didn't delete these
things
yeah well i am curious though the
movie's like around two hours 40 minutes
give or take did you have a cut that was
like three hours and 15 minutes or 3 30
and you're like i don't know how we're
getting it shorter
yeah i did i did
do you is it is there any chance we're
going to see like an extended cut or is
it just going to be deleted scenes no no
no because one thing i'll put it on
record
that
marvel
looked at me and said what cut do you
like this is what you ultimately want
you know it was a very collaborative
process and it's very few people there's
like two to three people i actually work
with on a daily basis to make these big
decisions and our editors
so
i i think is
the discipline
of
making sure you can tell the story
boil down to the essence of it it's
actually very important and because i've
added my previous work and i always you
know i usually have the opportunity to
screen it for an audience at the film
festival and i go home i look at the
reaction i go home i always shorten it
every single film map down
so in this case we were able to test it
with some audience we would be able to
see
the pacing you know and it's part of the
job to really pull things down to the
essence no completely so i'll ask as a
fan
do you know how many minutes of deleted
scenes you're going to release have you
figured that out we have about four
scenes for you
i don't know how many minutes
got it uh what was let me ask you this
what was the last thing
that you took out before you picture
locked what was that thing that was
there until like almost the end
oh my god i can't tell you i saw cameo
by someone very important to me but it
didn't quite work out got it i will
i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
i'm looking forward to seeing the
deleted scenes and if you ever want to
show you know a much longer cut i think
you would um have at least five people
that want to see it
thank you thank you you know listen i
hope it's a huge hit thank you so much
for your time thank you